I'm Lucy van der toten and I created
incredible edible cutlery army
to rid the planet of disposable plastic
cutlery and save the world one bite at a
time
this is [ __ ] incredible eatables
incredible edibles agree to disagree
are you ready for the ultimate
team-building challenge No
if we can navigate the deepest cave
systems of New Mexico then we can
navigate the challenges of today's
business environment
you okay
oh my god oh my god I'm CPR trained yep
pista it's a perfect team buildings
opportunity it's like our own private
escape room we are so [ __ ] I just want
to see if you needed something we've
taken this whole thing far enough to
anything physically possible it's been
days people no longer human being has
ever gone without food water is like a
week and we ran out of them there's one
food source that we haven't yet explored
what seriously we need to make this
decision as a team and there's no I in
team yeah but if you swap the letters
around it spells meat
okay let's get the [ __ ] out of this cake
let's go she's been wine steaming me
I'm not Weinstein to anyone number-one
rule just do whatever the [ __ ] I say the
second I say I can't do this nut up and
put that [ __ ] into it what would happen
if we drank our own bits we'd still die
of it the last thing we'd taste to be
our own piss
you
you